welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
to Florida where some of the most
popular beaches could be in for a
one-two punch of trouble just as
thousands of Spring Breakers visit the
Sunshine State and algae bloom known as
a red tide already killing fish along
the Gulf Coast is now causing a big old
stink now a massive blob of seaweed this
is threat number two this is wider than
the entire U.S it's drifting across the
Atlantic and it could wash ashore in the
coming weeks creating an even bigger
mess in Florida Manuel jorcas has more
from Florida
it is as foul smelling as it is
unsightly sea life dead and washed
ashore essentially choked by an algae
bloom known as red tide they appear to
be cleaned up at this beach in Naples on
Florida's Gulf Coast the smell that
lingered didn't stop tourists like
Melanie Coulter of Wisconsin when we
were walking from our car here I'm like
oh what is it that but on a bad day red
tide can have an impact on tourism as
businesses here are still recovering
from Hurricane Ian last year Logan
Fitzgerald measures it by the number of
beach chairs and umbrellas he rents a
day today there's a good amount of
people out here but Saturday wasn't too
good like not a lot of people were
coming out to the beach Saturday should
be a good day yeah it should be a good
day especially on spring break the ocean
breeze carries the toxin released by The
Red Tide algae ashore where it can cause
health problems for people from scratchy
throats to irritated eyes all the way
into difficulty breathing and asthma
attacks while it is a naturally
occurring algae this team from the water
school at Florida Gulf Coast University
is looking into whether pollution is
making the blooms worse it's probably
been the worst over the past two weeks
Mike Parsons is a professor here we've
had bad red tides in the past but the
big concern is now that our coastlines
are more developed and there's a lot
more people in Florida than there used
to be how are we affecting water quality
and how is that affecting red time and
what do we think there is evidence that
we are influencing red tide so pollution
may be aggravating the problem it may be
aggravating the problem it definitely is
not the cause of the problem but it may
be aggravating the problem now another
problem blooms on the horizon a 5 000
mile wide Patchwork of seaweed clumps in
the Atlantic captured in satellite
images is making its way toward the
Caribbean Mexico and Florida beaches in
the past the buildup of sargasm has been
so large and smelly heavy machinery was
brought in to clear it as that biomass
degrades it's going to release gases
things like hydrogen sulfide which smell
like rotten eggs but it's harmful and so
you don't want to be breathing that in a
lot would you advise against going in
the water if you go to a stretch of
Beach and you see dead fish and you
start getting a scratchy nose your eyes
are watering probably not the best idea
get a stay there
the potential impact of the seaweed here
is still weeks away the hope is red tide
will have subsided and all these
beachgoers will have to worry about is
catching a wave for CBS mornings Manuel
bojorquez Naples Florida
I mean I don't remember it being that
bad when I was a kid in Florida but I
also think I've been to spring break
before I've seen it I don't think those
college kids are going to Care
necessarily make a lot of things on
their mind I hope they do care well
Manny talked about how pollution's
aggravating the problem climate change
is also aggravated I'm sure it is
scientists yeah feel bad for those
people that have those vacations already
booked very very hard to step over at
dead fish and say hey come on in kids
the water's fine right right exactly